por segundo año consecutivo el mundo
conmemorar a la semana santa en medio de
restricciones
los gobiernos de países como chile perú
y venezuela- apostaron por el retorno a
la cuarentena estricta y el desarrollo
de actos religiosos virtuales colombia
decretó un toque de queda nocturno en
las ciudades con mayor índice de
ocupación de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos mientras paraguay impuso
restricciones de movilidad en todo su
territorio desde las 8 de la noche hasta
las 5 de la mañana
panamá prohibir a el ingreso de personas
provenientes de suramérica a partir del
miércoles y desde este domingo se exige
prueba pcr en brásil los gobiernos
locales cerraron las principales playas
a falta de una medida nacional y
argentina prohibió el ingreso de vuelos
desde méjico chile y brasil entretanto
en españa' algunos templos fueron
autorizados para abrir sus puertas con
un aforo limitado para los fieles que
cumplen con los requisitos de
bioseguridad en la comunidad de madrid'
serán desplegados cientos de agentes
hasta el 9 de abril para supervisar el
cumplimiento de las medidas
[Música]
positivos semejante al de navidad
la gente como
y si no fuese así por lo menos estar
preparados para esa posibilidad
prudencia
que creemos que va a ser grande dado que
seguimos con él
[Música]
para evitar el aumento de los casos las
autoridades sanitarias alemanas instaron
a los habitantes a evitar las
aglomeraciones y desplazamientos
innecesarios
necesitamos otros 10 o 14 días al menos
para reducir los contagios un bloqueo si
quieren llamarlo así como lo hicimos en
la semana santa del año pasado yo
también preferiría estar con el círculo
familiar pero este año todavía no
funciona
faingold en manila la capital filipina
las iglesias permanecen vacías desde el
24 de marzo cuando el presidente rodrigo
duterte advirtió a los católicos que
éstas serían cerradas por la fuerza si
los sacerdotes insistían en celebrar
misas- desafiando los controles